today i want to take a few minutes to
tell you about a really interesting tech
project called ethernet cloud we
partnered with ethernet cloud to create
this video so they support the david
pakman show help make the show possible
and we thank them for that it's been a
fascinating project to learn more about
so let's just dive right in ethernet
cloud is a decentralized confidential
computing platform on an ethereum
compatible blockchain what does that
mean
confidential computing is a pretty new
cloud computing technology takes an ar
an organization's most sensitive data
isolates it in a protected cpu while
it's being processed where stronger
end-to-end data security is provided
through exclusive control of the
encryption keys the data being processed
is only accessible to authorized
programming code it's invisible to
anyone else including whoever is
providing the cloud
ethernet cloud says that they've
developed
a
cloud computing
built specially for privacy anonymity
and availability they say their vision
about the future of cloud computing has
three important features it's encrypted
it's anonymous and it's continuously
available
and the fact that they're using
blockchain technology is a big part of
this it allows for a decentralized
ecosystem
where regular cloud software
runs as decentralized cloud app so
inside of ethernet cloud the nodes of
the blockchain are location agnostic
self-replicating and always spawning
around the internet without user
interaction this is the advantage of
combining cloud computing with
blockchain technology the
decentralization aspect is very cool
because they avoid the middleman that
you would normally have with centralized
cloud computing which ethernet cloud
says allows them to provide a more
trustless cost-effective and reliable
solution that does a better job of
empowering everyday users and users can
monetize their idle computing resources
join
public fog computing infrastructure and
then when you look at the privacy
advantages authority cloud says that by
providing encryption on all levels user
data is protected when it's at rest in
transit and during use or during
processing using this trustless model
the software enforces private uh privacy
security controls that provide peace of
mind to the owners of the data now with
regard to anonymity
when data is in a decentralized
environment like this
the anonymity is the key element that
ensures the right privacy levels
ethernet cloud says they have a special
understanding of the demand for
anonymity when running cloud computing
applications so it's one of the biggest
focuses or foci of what they do and then
finally the availability of the data
availability can be a challenge with
decentralized cloud storage and
processing models like this but that's
another problem that ethernet cloud
wants to solve they are adapting and
developing decentralized apps that run
seamlessly but also provide
uninterrupted availability one other
aspect of the technology i want to cover
is what's referred to as ethernet
cloud's proof of execution this is the
method by which computational tasks are
run in a decentralized way while the
tasks run
various metadata information is being
stored on the blockchain and the actual
data is transferred using the ipfs
protocol so using this method
computational tasks are certified on the
blockchain while at the same time
improving availability abil the ability
of the research to be reproduced
ethernet cloud is headed up by founder
and ceo joseph peterfie
who actually has over 20 years of
experience filling cornerstone tech
infrastructure roles at the usdod
the max planck digital library really
fascinating projects ethernet cloud had
a very successful pre-sale they've had a
ton of community support from the start
the public sale is scheduled for q3 this
year until that happens they have a
registration form where people can sign
up ahead of time ethernet cloud has
become a member of the confidential
computing consortium that's a community
focused on projects
for securing data and accelerating the
adoption of confidential computing
through open collaboration the ccc has a
really cool ethos if you read about them
on the website i think it says a lot
about ethernet cloud being a member i've
really enjoyed learning about ethernet
crowd while making a ethernet cloud
while making the video take a minute to
check out their website look at the
white paper check out the road map the
team is interesting read more about them
you can follow ethernet cloud on social
they're on twitter telegram discord
reddit they do a really good job job of
keeping the community updated
and the link to the ethernet cloud
website is underneath the video
thank you to ethernet cloud for
partnering with us on this video and as
i always make sure to say in every
partnered video we do
nothing in this video is financial
advice of any kind